oui oui oui le lie à qu'elle aimera
apparemment que bonjour de quelqu'un
j'ai besoin d'un temps celui qui répond
bien à deux questions gagner le jeu or
comme syrie et le champion le challenger
a le droit de donner une réponse au
premier si c'est la bonne il marque le
point on passe à la question suivante la
carre compris auriez henriette première
question question sciences et vie de la
terre
quels organes du corps humain est
composé de deux oreillettes et de deux
ventricules à je le sais le cas et ça
c'est une bonne réponse
juste pour savoir qui est pour moi qui
ai pour jean minutes ou le clavier est à
vous bien sûr on vous et vos amis ou vos
gens me mo jean-mi beau vous oui vous
vous cyril jean-mi niveau professionnel
vous largement et je sais qu'elle est
toujours contre moi donc c'est
jean-louis à elle est contente plus
droit à l'erreur pour cirer la deuxième
question question géographique cinéma
media active is est inscrite sur le
drapeau du brésil à des notes non non
non c'est déjà trop tard
ai-je appris à cordes m2 dont 1 5
milliard d'âmes bas partout il faut le
voile alors est ce que moi je sais juste
oui mais je m'en fous je suis allé chez
riches et qui fait très chaude heures je
crois qu'on a une caméra d'or juste pour
voir s'il fait toujours aussi chaud
oui c'est vrai quoi la can est tellement
chaud dehors est ce qu'on peut vérifier
wee aa oui oui ah bah oui regardez fait
tellement chaud il ya des gens qui
autorise mais non garantis mais oui mais
oui mais non voix a oui ah oui ordonne
époux le progrès son voile ah oui vous
n'avez pas honte
ah non pas pour l'instant tout va bien
quelle devise d'inscrits sur le drapeau
du brésil syrie c'est à vous de répondre
deviendront les woerth m ouais ouais
crois que c'est ordem il fait plonger
son premier congrès sont ok ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire si tu dors tu va
progresser j adore dans ta chambre tu au
rangement tâche en vous par les
portugais depuis combien de temps vous
l'a écouté les formes
bon ça va vous paraître étonnant mais la
devise du drapeau du brésil c'est ordem
et progresso
[Applaudissements]
appliquant
à
[Applaudissements]
oui oui oui le lie à quel émoi
apparemment que mon jour de quelqu'un
j'ai besoin d'un terrain
dégagez ramener mon bac 1 juste les gars
quand vous faites un faux bac qui avait
mis un bac en sciences j'avais eu un bac
en sciences économiques et sociales si
c'est pas du tout avec des épées 1,74 à
balai merci mamie et surtout vous l'avez
eu comme en 2001 à 26 ans se joue sur
cette question histoire histoire bête
fois en histoire tous les deux bref moi
et j'ai des notions alors dans le
calendrier républicain quel nom était
attribuée au 25e jour du mois de
germinal exactement dans des domaines
jusque là enfin je sais pas dire là
dessus on me dit qu'en fait juste parce
que j'ai un truc en fait il ya quelqu'un
qui voudrait en parler à qui ça va mal
m'en tombent à l'eau qui soit à sion
qu'est-ce que vous avez essayé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors la question c'était dans le
calendrier républicain quel nom était
attribuée au 25e jour du mois de
germinal ne serait pas utile ou alors
des gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thomas marty n'avais pas le bac mais
chérie je suis le seul animateur à faire
l'émission occupation
[Rires]
[Musique]